this is the equation that we're working
with okay it's already been factored as
for you so let's start to read things
off the first thing I'm looking forward
the intercepts right so when you have a
look the first one like that X at the
front means that i can put in x equals 0
that'll be one of the x-intercepts right
from this next one over here I'm getting
the opposite x equals negative 3 will
also be intercept and the last one is
what number do i put into here is that
last set of brackets what number do i
put in to make that last set of brackets
0 it'll be our five or two or two and a
half right to two and a half is my last
x intercept fantastic dump now to find
out y intercepts remember i said let x
equal 0 at x equals you're okay hon I've
already I've already worked out if x
equals 0 the whole thing is 0 right so
as soon as you see x equals 0 is an
x-intercept that's also a y-intercept
right y equals 0 also oh and she said
that so I've kind of done that's the
origin right 00 okay intercepts are out
of the way now I want to figure out
what's happening at the edges of the
graph right because I know zero minus
one two three and one two two and a half
I know that's what's happening in like
the middle of the graph but what's
happening to the edges okay now if you
have a look at this I'll do an extra
step which I didn't say you had to do
but it will actually top all of us okay
if you take this guy and you expand you
right remember I said the most important
term is the big term the leading term
the one with the arm the one with the
biggest power on the degree do you
remember that so when I expand this I'm
actually not going to worry about most
of the terms I just want the leading
term ok what's the power of this going
to be which what's the degree of this
ground it's three there Vic you bakir so
therefore in order to get a cubit out of
this space
I mean I don't have to do every single
term by every single term for instance I
don't have to do x times 3 times
negative 5 I don't need to worry about
that because that doesn't have 3 x's in
it there's only one term that will have
3 x's in it it'll be this one time to
this one times this one that is that so
if i just multiply those guys if I'm
just interested in those guys right if i
combine them i get an x cubed obviously
but what's the coefficient at the front
of that X what not but gets attached to
it there's a negative on 102 so when you
multiply them all together you get
negative 2 okay now when you start to
put in like let me put in a huge
positive number for X right this die the
X cubed he gets huge and positive but
then there's a minus sign out the front
do you see that right so this is a
formal way of writing I didn't tell you
about it before because you don't need
the forward right but you can write it
as well if you like when X is getting to
a really big in a positive infinity
right huge numbers what's why do we well
it's getting really really negative do
you see that like x is huge but minus 2
times X cubed is really negative huge
okay it doesn't take too much thought to
see when you do the opposite the
opposite people happen okay so that
means that off on the left hand side I'm
coming from up here I'm coming from a
positive infinity when i'll come in from
the left hand side that's the left-right
negative infinity whereas when x is
positive infinity that's at the right
and it's going down it's dropping like a
rock okay so start up here and I'm going
to end down there okay and that idea
that it comes from the leading
coefficient that minus 2 alright that's
actually quite important all right I'm
ready to join the dots down does yours
look something on this starts from the
top comes down which threw that into
sales head down again that's it now let
me make one last note before we move on
to this our last item here you might
notice that the graph these cubed graphs
right they turn around a couple of times
right you see it it's coming down and
then it turns around it comes back up
and it turns around again it goes back
down okay because these are points where
the graph turns around are very
originally pathogens pulleys turning
points okay now you don't need to know
it that they didn't call right but i
just want to point out where are these
turning points okay like I've got this
one here and here how do I know where
they are and the short answer is I don't
I mean I know roughly where they're
going to be like obviously it's going to
be between minus 30 it's got to be tween
02 and a half but like up and down I
don't know where it is this guy over
here is he to the left or is it to the
right should I have drawn it like more
like this so the 20-point is over there
now the short answer is at the moment I
don't know at the moment I don't know
just like you know in the past if you've
got given this graph here on write the
equation in this graph and I asked you
graphic you'd say I don't know okay next
year when you learn calculus when you
achieve it we learn the tools for
finding where these things are call
where these worthies turning points
where they're located okay but at the
moment you can draw them anywhere
because you don't have access to the
tools that can locate them
you